de pouvoir donner une écho à ce à ce
sujet qui est particulièrement
d'actualité
dans cette délégation à la prospective
et votre sujet à une vision une vision
tout à l'heure en aparté prospective et
nous intéressons donc à ce sujet de la
démondialisation à travers
cette audition
aujourd'hui nous allons traiter plus
particulièrement des échanges
économiques à travers le concept
relativement nouveau ce concept
relativement nouveau de démondialisation
vous avez d'ailleurs consacré
l'ouvrage consacré le temps dénommé par
le temps de la démondialisation chez
Guillaume vit mais vous êtes docteur en
économie professeur de finance HEC vous
travaillez notamment sur les questions
de responsabilité des entreprises et sur
l'histoire économique ce matin vous
allez donc comme je disais nous éclairer
sur un sujet particulièrement
transversal la question des échanges qui
touchent en effet au secteur de
l'économie de l'agriculture au moment où
on va se refermer le Salon international
de l'agriculture l'industrie les
services longtemps nous avons été
persuadés des échanges presque illimités
de la mondialisation nous pensions
qu'elle était source de croissance et
donc de bienfaits pour notre économie et
nos citoyens aujourd'hui nous en sommes
un peu revenus avec par exemple les
pénuries de masques de médicaments
l'invasion de marché du photovoltaïque
par les panneaux solaires chinois ou
encore la dépendance de nos éleveurs au
soja importé pour nourrir leurs animaux
sans parler bien sûr des conséquences en
termes de perte d'emploi de fermeture
d'usine sur nos territoires ainsi que de
coups environnemental dans ce contexte
comment peut-on envisager cette
démondialisation dont vous dites que le
temps est arrivé nos économies ne sont
pas ne sont-elles pas pardon trop
imbriquées et interdépendantes pour
imaginer que cela puisse arriver quel
levier faudrait-il mettre en oeuvre
peut-on espérer un avantage non
seulement pour notre économie mais
également pour nos territoires
aura-t-elle à l'inverse un coût pour nos
concitoyens et pensez-vous que ce
concept un avenir en Europe et dans le
reste du monde voilà pour les premières
questions en guise d'introduction que je
tenais à vous poser avant que nous
passions à ce temps d'échange je vais
vous laisser maintenant la parole pour
que vous puissiez introduire et
développer ce sujet et ce concept de
démondialisation merci en tout cas
Guillaume bien merci à vous pour votre
invitation merci à vous tous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et donc on va
essayer effectivement de passer un petit
peu de temps pour essayer de comprendre
ce concept pourquoi je pense qu'il est
important ou pourquoi d'autres concepts
d'ailleurs liés un concept qui monte et
qui je crois est très important dont je
parlerai également et celui de BIM
mondialisation on verra de quoi de quoi
il s'agit
pour faire très simple je crois que le
temps de la mondialisation telle qu'on
l'a connu et plus ou moins finie ce qui
ne veut pas dire évidemment qu'il y aura
plus d'échanges internationaux ce qui
veut pas dire qu'on va revenir où on
pouvait en être il y a 30 ou 40 ans mais
on rentre dans un monde assez nouveau et
pour comprendre pour deux raisons
fondamentales je crois sur lesquels je
vais revenir et avant ça je voudrais
faire un très bref retour en arrière sur
l'interprétation de la mondialisation
telle qu'on tel qu'on l'a eu depuis
plusieurs décennies pendant très
longtemps on a voulu juger la
mondialisation et les économistes
notamment n'ont voulu juger la
mondialisation que du point de vue du
consommateur quasiment sur tous les
sujets on s'est dit est-ce que ça
bénéficie ou pas au consommateur est-ce
que ça fait en gros plus de bien à des
prix plus bas et dès qu'on s'est posé
des questions de politique publique on
s'est dit c'est bon pour le consommateur
c'est le traité est bon pour le
consommateur parce que ça fera baisser
les prix de temps ou de s'offrira
davantage de bien à des prix à des prix
plus bas bon
tout ça est évidemment vrai et c'est
évidemment vrai que du point de vue
strictement du consommateur la
mondialisation a eu des bienfaits assez
considérables tout le problème c'est que
cet argument n'était pas complet et je
crois que ce qui est très fondamental
qui est peut-être l'argument centrale de
mon livre c'est que l'extrême abondance
de biens privés a eu pour conséquence
une très grande raréfaction des biens
communs et finalement on ne voyant la
mondialisation le libre-échange que par
le biais du consommateur et ben on a
oublié
les collectivités les peuples les
territoires les intérêts publics les
intérêts communs etc et donc c'est très
réflexion des biens communs c'est
évidemment la dégradation de la nature
c'est évidemment une perte d'équilibre
je crois des modèles sociaux notamment
la inégalités qui sont devenues beaucoup
plus criants ça peut être la perte du
sentiment d'appartenance l'oubli de
savoir faire de territoires ça peut
aussi être évidemment l'oubli d'intérêt
d'intérêt stratégiques alors pourquoi
est-ce que je dis que le temps de la
démondialisation est venu je crois qu'il
y a deux raisons fondamental la première
c'est des raisons qui nous sont en
partie extérieure
et que en tant que en tant que Français
ou en tant qu'Européen on va en partie
subir et on n'a pas vraiment le choix
parce que le contexte mondial a changé
et la position de la France ou de
l'Europe ou de l'Occident dans le monde
n'est plus celle qu'elle était il y a
quelques décennies donc ça c'est
évidemment des choses à prendre en
compte on ne décide pas seul et la
deuxième je crois qu'on a aussi même
s'il y avait pas cet environnement
mondial nous-mêmes intérêt à
démondialiser pour justement
réintroduire davantage cette perspective
des biens communs des biens publics dans
la vie quotidienne dans la vie de nos
territoires dans la vie de nos pays et
même dans la vie peut-être de notre de
notre continent alors quelles sont ces
facteurs qui ne dépendent pas de nous
bah très simplement cette mondialisation
qui n'était jugée que par le prisme
essentiellement par le prisme du du
consommateur et des gains privés pour le
consommateur donc des gains individuels
finalement étaient une vision très très
américaine et et et ensuite europ de la
mondialisation mais que ce bloc
euro-américain occidental si l'on veut
et bien
perd en poids chaque année sur la scène
du monde depuis l'an dernier ou
peut-être depuis deux ans les pays du G7
qui rappelons-le inclus ni la Chine ni
la Russie ni l'Inde ni le Brésil etc
représente moins de 10% de la population
mondiale on est passé sous le soleil des
10% de la population mondiale bon
en termes de de richesse nette qu'on le
G7 a été écrit dans les années 70 on
représentait un peu près deux tiers de
la richesse mondiale on est passé depuis
plusieurs années sous la barre des 50%
et ça continue évidemment à décliner et
donc la vision de la mondialisation que
pouvait porter le G7 et bien ça faitblit
chaque année avec la montée corrélative
d'autres puissances qui on va le voir
ont une vision assez différente et je
crois que notamment
cette ce monde émergent à effectivement
une vision très différente je vais vous
donner quelques exemples
un sur la Chine
plusieurs sur la Chine d'autres sur
l'Inde l'un par exemple a annoncé
récemment vouloir viser à horizon de
quelques décennies une autonomie
alimentaire une auto-finance alimentaire
complètement c'est quelque chose d'assez
nouveau et de et de très important la
Chine depuis une dizaine d'années donc
sous le la présidence de sigin Ping
a profondément repensé son modèle pour
ne plus juger du libre-échange
principalement du point de vue
uniquement du consommateur individuel
mais avant tout des intérêts
commun de la Chine bon je vais donner
quelques exemples qui m'ont beaucoup
intéressé qui sont très frappants je
crois la Chine mène depuis quelques
années ou intensifie depuis quelques
années une politique d'infrastructure
stratégique absolument considérable
il y a je donnais quelques exemples et
on pourra évidemment développer pendant
les questions sur la question des des
technologies numériques
il y a deux trois ans si Jean Ping
annonce remplacer 100% des ordinateurs
et des systèmes informatiques de l'État
chinois et des entreprises publiques
chinoises donc on parle de dizaines de
millions d'ordinateurs pour qu'il n'y
ait plus une puce américaine dans les
systèmes informatiques chinois bon donc
l'idée qu'il y aura une infrastructure
informatique mondiale unique qui était
un peu fondatrice de l'Internet l'idée
d'Internet libre etc n'existe plus
autre infrastructure centrale de la
mondialisation que j'ai aussi beaucoup
étudié les systèmes de paiement bon
on le sait l'essentiel décide des
paiements aujourd'hui entre banque se
font via le système Swift bon quand
Swift avait été créé ça avait été placé
en Belgique pour être justement une
infrastructure neutre qui pourrait être
utilisée par tous les pays de la planète
sans discrimination aujourd'hui
ceci cette vision est morte aujourd'hui
Swift est vu dans le monde comme une
infrastructure américaine parce qu'il y
a des accords alors les Américains ont
espionner Swift et puis
depuis en des accords de partage de
données avec Swift et donc aujourd'hui
la Chine développe un système de
paiement qui gagne en ampleur chaque
année qui s'appelle Sims Chinese
international Penon system et qui a
vocation à être un système de paiement
alternatif à Swift bon donc à nouveau
complètement différent
de du système de paiement unique qui
supportait la mondialisation telle qu'on
a pu le voir un autre sujet qui je crois
est très central c'est celui des
monnaies numériques de banque centrale
la Chine a aujourd'hui une avance
considérable en matière de paiement
numérique de banque centrale CBDC en
anglais
avec un redmi numérique qui est déjà
utilisé par des dizaines de millions ou
des centaines de millions peut-être de
ménage chinois au quotidien cette
monnaie numérique se fait sans le
recours au système bancaire donc sans
aucune infrastructure
sous contrôle
occidental ou américain et est en train
de se diffuser le long de ce qu'ils
appellent les nouvelles routes de la
soie en Asie centrale essentiellement et
très largement très largement en Afrique
en matière de semi-conducteur
la Chine comme les États-Unis d'ailleurs
développe une politique d'autonomie
beaucoup plus forte ils veulent plus
être dépendant de fabricant américain
pour les semis conducteurs et donc je
crois que cette idée
le monde l'idée qu'on pouvait avoir d'un
monde unifié par le commerce
existe de moins en moins ce qu'on a
beaucoup plus c'est ce que ce que ce que
ce qu'une spécialiste de la Chine Alice
ecman appelé la bimondialisation
vraiment l'idée je crois que les
infrastructures essentielles aux
échanges sont en train de se fragmenter
selon des lignes de plus en plus
géopolitiques et logique politique sont
finalement en train de prendre le dessus
sur des logiques purement économiques et
d'efficacité économique
et un autre concept je crois est très
important pour comprendre la manière
dont des pays comme la Chine ou l'Inde
justement pense pensent le monde et vous
êtes en train de monter quel concept
d'État civilisationnel qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire la Chine ou l'Inde ne se pense
pas comme et c'est notamment vrai de la
Chine mais aussi d'autres d'autres pays
on pourrait penser également à la
Turquie ou à l'Iran peut-être ne se
pense pas comme un pays
indifférencier sur la carte du monde qui
pourrait simplement échanger acheter et
vendre les mêmes bien que la planète
entière au même condition il pense
qu'ils ont qui sont plus qu'un agrégat
de consommateur et qu'ils ont vraiment
une vision propre de la culture un
héritage civilisationnel très long à
portée ce qui est très frappant chez les
dirigeants chinois si on lit leur
discours c'est qu'ils font très très
souvent références à des penseurs qui
peuvent avoir 2000 ou 2500 ans quand il
parle de Confucius ou de mensus c'est
très rare sous nos latitudes
il y a une idée de continuité et de
singularité en Chine du modèle collectif
qui va donc au delà
des bénéfices du libre-échange pour le
consommateur qui est très forte et qui
guide je crois une vision complètement
différente de l'ordre de l'ordre mondial
bon
là-dessus il y a évidemment autre chose
qui va rajouter une contrainte très
forte c'est la raréfaction progressive
de beaucoup de ressources naturelles
évidemment on pourrait se dire beaucoup
de métaux par exemple évidemment les les
hydrocarbures et les énergies fossiles
mais aussi beaucoup de métaux vont être
de plus en plus rares beaucoup de terres
rares et ce serait très important qu'on
se justement qu'on se coordonne de plus
en plus pour essayer de de les gérer et
de les allouer efficacement etc
malheureusement ça a peu de chance
d'être le cas ce qui est plus probable à
mes yeux c'est que plus des ressources
seront rares moins leur allocations à
l'échelle du monde se fera selon les
principes du libre-échange et plus ça se
fera selon des lignes de fracture qui
seront politiques géopolitiques et on
ira je crois vers une
une allocation de plus en plus politique
des ressources à l'échelle à l'échelle
du monde ça c'est pour les facteurs qui
ne dépendent pas ou très peu de nous et
qui quand bien même on voudrait
continuer avec la mondialisation telle
qu'on la connu beaucoup de partenaires
de plus en plus gros de plus en plus
importants économiquement
démographiquement ne le ne le voudront
pas euro une vision très différente de
la mondialisation mais je crois que même
s'il y avait pas ça il y a aussi des
facteurs intérieurs qui doivent nous
pousser à à réfléchir de manière assez
critique sur la mondialisation et à
vouloir rechercher d'autres d'autres
modèles je crois que je vous le disais
au début
je crois que notre
tout est bien fait de la mondialisation
qu'on a vu qui sont voilà on peut avoir
ou accès à beaucoup plus de biens à des
prix beaucoup plus bas qui a 30 ou 40
ans et c'est traduit par une raréfaction
des biens communs des biens publics et
que cette raréfaction ou cette
dégradation des biens communs a atteint
des proportions qui sont deviennent
relativement insoutenables c'est vrai
évidemment de la dégradation des milieux
naturels c'est vrai je crois aussi d'une
certaine
certains équilibres sociales qui ont été
trop perturbés notamment matière
d'inégalité sociale mais aussi
territoriale la question évidemment de
la de la France périphérique est très
très importante à mes yeux et donc je
crois que
un point très fondamental c'est que les
les coûts de transport ont été beaucoup
trop bas j'ai pour ma part beaucoup
travaillé sur la question de du
transport maritime qui est central dans
la mondialisation
après 80 à 90% de tout ce qui traverse
les frontières ou de tout ce qui est
échangé mondialement se fait par voie
maritime les avions ou les trains c'est
assez marginal c'est 80 à 90% seulement
qu'on compte en valeur ou en volume
c'est des portes containers
ces portes containers c'est très
intéressant
donc dans le cadre de travaux
universitaires que j'ai fait à HEC j'ai
pu acheter les données portuaires sur
l'ensemble des bateaux de la planète
donc je peux voir l'ensemble des portes
containers ou des tankers ou de tous les
navires que vous voulez de la planète et
puis voir par exemple c'est très
intéressant l'augmentation des pavillons
de complaisance depuis 40 ans dans le
transport maritime bon il y a pour faire
très simple il y a 40 ans ça commence
vraiment à s'accélérer dans les années
80 ça existait déjà évidemment un peu
avant mais beaucoup moins et bien un
avis qui disons était possédés par une
entreprise française ou qui était qui
avait des marins français et bien était
généralement immatriculé en France avait
un pavillon français bon aujourd'hui ça
n'existe plus ou quasiment plus
aujourd'hui 80 à 90% de toute la flotte
mondiale est immatriculée dans des
pavillons de complaisance dans les trois
dont les trois principaux sont le
Liberia le Panama les îles Marshall je
peux en rajouter quelques autres mais
c'est principalement principalement ces
trois là et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
et bien ça veut dire quelque chose de
très simple ça veut dire que c'est
pavillon de complaisance
ont une capacité ou offre en tout cas
une évasion fiscale un peu près
systématique le taux d'imposition
en matière de enfin pour les sociétés
étrangères immatriculées dans ces
pays-là et classiquement de 0%
ça veut dire évidemment une évasion
réglementaire très souvent en matière de
droit du travail en matière de droit de
l'environnement en matière de
réglementation technique etc ça veut
aussi dire une évasion en termes de
responsabilité juridique ça veut dire
que s'il y a un dommage typiquement une
marinée noire et bien ce sera beaucoup
plus compliqué pour un juge par exemple
français d'aller
chercher le propriétaire
ultime d'un navire s'il est immatriculé
ou Liberia c'est d'ailleurs il n'a
qu'une qu'une boîte postale souvent en
Liberia
donc c'est très compliqué donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que cette
tendance là où pendant 40 ans disant on
est passé d'un monde où le commerce
maritime restait relativement lié au
territoire et aux environnements
réglementaires des grandes puissances
maritimes a complètement été déplacée
vers des pavillons de complaisance vers
des juridictions complaisantes et bien
ça abaissé considérablement les coûts de
transport et c'est en grande partie
puisque
quasiment tout passe par le transport
maritime c'est en grande partie ce qui
fait qu'on a pu délocaliser autant qu'on
l'a fait bon aujourd'hui on a des
exemples absolument sidérant vous en
connaissez probablement tous le poisson
pêché au large des côtes de Bretagne
qu'on emmène en Chine pour le vider et
qu'on réimporte de Chine pour le vendre
dans un supermarché en France le chêne
qui est coupé dans les forêts françaises
qui est exporté en Chine pour être
découpé en planche et qui est dans les
planches sont réimportées en Europe etc
on pourrait et donc tout ça évidemment
n'est possible que parce que les coûts
de transport ont été abaissés dans des
proportions
considérables et probablement beaucoup
trop considérable du point de vue des
bienfaits collectifs des bienfaits
sociaux évidemment un nouveau si on ne
voit que le point de vue du consommateur
si on fait tout ça c'est parce que parce
qu'on gagne quelques centimes du point
de vue du consommateur mais on peut
légitimement à mes yeux se demander si
socialement la pollution causée par ce
transport maritime n'est pas trop
important entre relativement bénéfice si
les coûts associés à la
désindustrialisation à la perte d'emploi
à la perte de savoir-faire ne sont pas
trop importants évidemment il y a des
coûts directs économiques il y a aussi
notamment aux États-Unis depuis quelques
années toute une très grande littérature
scientifique très intéressante qui
montre aussi des coûts qui vont bien
au-delà de la perte d'emploi mais qui
peuvent être par exemple des taux de
divorce beaucoup plus élevés dans les
chaises aux États-Unis alors
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens en
France qui sont les plus exposés
consommation de drogue plus élevée taux
de divorce plus élevé fait taux de
fécondité plus bas etc donc il y a
évidemment des conséquences extra
économiques je crois très importantes en
la en la matière donc
démondialisé dans ce cadre là ça va
vouloir dire quoi ça vouloir dire et
bien
davantage prendre en compte ces coûts
collectif et en essayant de trouver des
moyens de réduire la mobilité
d'absolument tout et n'importe quoi à
l'échelle du monde ce qui est à nouveau
ne veut pas dire arrêter complètement
toute forme de commerce à ce qui serait
ce qui serait ridicule mais essayez de
réintroduire un équilibre entre intérêt
commun intérêt stratégique intérêt
collectif bien public et puis simplement
bénéfice pour le pour le consommateur
alors avant de d'ouvrir aux questions de
derniers éléments quand on pense à la
démondialisation je crois qu'il y a deux
manières fondamentales de la pensée il y
a une démondialisation qui pourrait être
simplement subie qui serait simplement à
mon avis un risque très important qui
serait dire ben on s'attache à une
vision
de la mondialisation telle qu'on l'a
connu et on se ferme les yeux finalement
à ce qui se passe dans le monde
notamment à ce qui se passe en Asie mais
pas uniquement et finalement on serait
condamné en permanence à regretter que
la Chine prenne-t-elle décision que
l'Inde prenne-t-elle décision que les
États-Unis aujourd'hui prennent
l'infection réduction actes et puis on
irait de pénurie en pénurie ou de
problèmes stratégiques en problèmes
stratégiques ça c'est évidemment une
démondialisation qui ne serait à mes
yeux assez catastrophique et puis je
crois que notre vision qui serait dire
et bien il faut aussi que nous Français
nous Européens et même nous à l'échelle
des territoires beaucoup plus locaux je
crois que ça peut se faire à tous les à
tous les échelons on prennent conscience
et bien qu'on a des des biens communs à
protéger des intérêts stratégiques à
protéger des milles naturelles à
protéger des équilibres sociaux et des
savoir-faire à protéger et qui vont bien
au-delà de la
des bienfaits qu'on a pu avoir pour le
consommateur de la mondialisation depuis
plus assez longtemps alors
comment faire ça je crois qu'il y a il y
a évidemment pas de solution miracle
mais je crois qu'il y a un éventail de
choses auquel on peut on peut réfléchir
je crois que déjà c'est très important
quand en France et en Europe on est un
débats beaucoup plus importants sur les
infrastructures proprement stratégiques
pendant très longtemps on s'est appuyé
sur sur Swift sur des serveurs sur des
câbles sous-marins etc qui sont
quasiment exclusivement en européens
alors aujourd'hui principalement
américain un tout petit peu chinois ça
commence mais malheureusement très très
peu très très peu français ou très très
peu européen donc il y a des vrais
enjeux à avoir là-dessus sur les
questions d'infrastructures stratégique
je parlais de de monnaie numérique de
banque centrale
très rapidement au début de mon
intervention la Banque centrale
européenne commence à y réfléchir mais
malheureusement à mes yeux le partenaire
qu'elle choisisse c'est Amazon qui pas
une société européenne bon donc à
nouveau en termes d'indépendance
stratégique c'est peut-être un petit peu
douteux bien
je crois que il y a aussi d'autres
éléments sur lesquels on peut réfléchir
un sujet sur lequel je travaille
beaucoup en ce moment c'est la question
de la responsabilité territoriale des
entreprises aujourd'hui il y a un sujet
extrêmement à la mode quel sujet de la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises et
malheureusement souvent ça cache
beaucoup de choses très différentes mais
bien souvent on a une vision très
abstraite très mondiale de la
responsabilité sociale qui peut par
exemple consister à dire et bien je
dégrade un milieu naturel ici mais c'est
pas très grave parce que je compense par
une donation à une ONG à l'autre bout du
monde
et donc c'est à mes yeux assez douteux
et ça peut cacher beaucoup de
greenwashing je crois que la vraie
responsabilité des entreprises qui ont
voulu la mesurer et l'évaluer dans un
contexte
de
retéritorialisation elle doit être avant
toute territoriale c'est la valeur
ajoutée d'une entreprise pour un
territoire donné et je travaille en ce
moment à des mesures de ce genre de ce
genre de choses
et puis je crois qu'il y a une réflexion
aussi plus fondamentale à avoir
notamment sur le transport maritime sa
régulation son cadre réglementaire
voilà quelques pistes il y en a
évidemment beaucoup d'autres
merci beaucoup avant de laisser la
parole au collègues peut-être de trois
interrogations et réflexions
personnelles à commencer par le dernier
sujet que vous venez d'évoquer le
transport le transport maritime et
peut-être de façon plus générale vous
posez une question par rapport à
votre propos c'est à ton réellement les
moyens de de parvenir à une
démondialisation quand on voit je le
disais tout à l'heure en préambule que
nos économies sont de plus en plus
imbriquées vous avez parlé notamment de
la question de la Route de la Soie on
pourrait parler s'agissant notamment
des accords de libre-échange que sont le
CETA le Mercosur et qui quoi qu'on en
pense
pose des questions notamment sur en
matière de sécurité alimentaire en
matière de de rapport entre nos
différentes
agricultures et des questions de normes
les questions sanitaires j'ajouterai à
cela que nous sommes dans un pays
qui importe de plus en plus je parlais
tout à l'heure du salon de l'agriculture
c'est ces produits agricoles alors
qu'elle était le grenier de l'Europe et
que nous avons toujours misé sur une
agriculture productive et je pense que
tout ceci
pose quand même le sujet en lien direct
avec ce que vous disiez et par la même
en creux à ton les moyens de cette
démondialisation tu vois question du
transport maritime j'entends et je
souscris à ce que vous dites en revanche
pour avoir vu notamment dans deux
bassins et que sont l'océan Indien et
l'océan Atlantique notamment sur la
partie Caraïbes le poids aujourd'hui
exercé par par la Chine non seulement
bien sûr sur les sur les échanges vous
avez parlé des
[Musique]
c'est peut-être plus simple pour une
économie allemande dont on sait que
c'est ETI sont en lien très direct avec
avec le territoire que qu'elle échelon
français donc on voit que là aussi on a
des référentiels qui sont un petit peu
un petit peu différents voilà en clair
quelques observations mais qui qui
reviennent toutes et tous tous pardon à
cette question centrale c'est à ton
aujourd'hui les moyens de de pouvoir se
diriger
sans dégâts collatéraux entre guillemets
vers une démondialisation et faire en
sorte que le coût social le coût pour
nos concitoyens ne sont pas trop forts
et je ne parle pas simplement que les
quelques centimes auxquels vous avez
fait référence s'agissant de l'achat de
bois ou d'autres ou d'autres biens qui
sont sont produits ou fabriqués ici même
en France les matières premières
également donc c'était pour avoir votre
finalement votre retour et votre réponse
sur comment en fait on parvient à faire
une dém la mondialisation j'ai pas
évoqué un autre sujet nous avons commis
il y a quelques semaines un rapport sur
l'avenir de l'eau certains des
rapporteurs sont ici et on voit bien que
la géopolitique aussi de l'eau c'est un
sujet essentiel on peut être un état
particulier
on a été avec Catherine bellrity il y a
quelques mois en Malaisie à Singapour si
demain la Malaisie ferme le robinet
Singapour et c'est milliards font de
réserve non plus aucune capacité à agir
y compris à honorer leurs ambitions en
matière finalement de taux de production
en matière d'alimentation sur leur
territoire voilà donc autant de sujets
qui qui montrent vraiment cette
imbrication et donc peut-être la
complexité que cela peut revêtir de
d'arriver à
cette ambition qu'on partage avec vous
bien évidemment
alors évidemment très très beaucoup de
questions
quelques éléments de réponse ou de
réflexion parce qu'évidemment il y a
beaucoup de questions ouvertes aussi
également j'ai pas de solution miracle
pour tout je crois qu'effectivement le
il s'agit pas tant de renoncer au aux
imbrications et aux interdépendants que
ou de les construire sur un mode sur un
une vision du monde complètement
différente aujourd'hui nos imbrications
sont principalement le raisin soit
purement économique où on se disait et
bah tiens c'est moins cher d'acheter là
donc on va acheter là etc il s'agit je
crois qu'il s'agit l'important c'est au
niveau de remettre du politique dans
l'économie et donc d'abord une réflexion
beaucoup plus stratégique sur quelques
priorités
à l'échelle de la France à l'échelle de
l'Europe évidemment on ne retirera pas
tout on n'aura jamais une économie qui
sera beaucoup moins interdépendante mais
il s'agit je crois de penser
l'interdépendance non plus uniquement
sous le mode de la dépendance économique
en fonction du prix le plus bas etc mais
d'avoir de savoir quel partenaire
stratégique on a en matière géopolitique
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a par
exemple un débat qui va être très
important sur les rapports entre comment
est-ce que l'Europe va se situer dans
les décennies à venir entre les
États-Unis et la Chine qui va être un
débat très important ou est-ce que
l'Europe aura une position médiane une
position d'alliance ou pas et dont le
savoir sur quel sujet on on accepte par
exemple des infrastructures stratégiques
chinoises américaine ou est-ce qu'on
essaie vraiment de développer de la
structure européenne donc il y a plus
que de renoncer aux interdépendances il
faut savoir
quel type de dépendance on veut et avec
une dimension politique et stratégique
ça tu crois c'est très important et ça
suppose un débat très ouvert et très
libre je vous poser des questions là
et après je croyais effectivement des
cas et je crois que l'agriculture est un
très bon exemple où on veut probablement
la France a été très excédentaire dans
sa balance commerciale agricole pendant
quasiment probablement depuis depuis ses
origines et aujourd'hui est déficitaire
bon donc c'est évidemment une situation
qui interroge ou qui pose beaucoup de
questions et qui est probablement aussi
résultat de peut-être de mauvais choix
politiques ou en tout cas de politique
qui pourrait être mieux menée ou
peut-être du fait qu'on a renoncé avoir
l'agriculture comme vous de profondément
stratégique et et ça encore je crois que
le le débat doit avoir de manière
beaucoup plus ouverte quelles sont les
secteurs stratégiques pour l'économie
française et qu'elles sont ceux qui ne
le sont pas mais je crois que le
préalable c'est évidemment la réflexion
stratégique qui doit guider une vision
de ce qui finalement peut être laissée
ouvert à une mondialisation finalement
très peu très peu régulée et quels sont
les secteurs qui sont réellement
stratégiques prioritaires ou le
politique doit et où la vision de long
terme doit jouer un rôle doit jouer
beaucoup plus important je crois que
c'est le la manière de voir de voir les
choses et après sur les outils ils sont
évidemment très nombreux moins un outil
par exemple qui est très simple mais je
crois qu'il marche assez bien et que
j'aime beaucoup et qui malheureusement
est attaqué à chaque traité de
libre-échange c'est par exemple les
labels la politique de dire et bien il y
a des produits des appellations
d'origine contrôlée qui sont faits sur
des territoires qui peuvent être un
savoir-faire à une culture un milieu un
territoire et et qui mérite d'être
protégé en tant que tel je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui a qui a beaucoup
de valeur qui est assez efficace pour
pour protéger des des territoires et qui
malheureusement est attaqué à peu près à
chaque traité de libre-échange
finalement je crois que on a vécu dans
une on avait une vision du monde pendant
très longtemps on se disait la situation
par défaut doit être le le libre-échange
un peu près sans limite et puis par
exception on peut tolérer quelques
labels quelques exceptions etc et donc
il y avait toujours quelque chose d'un
peu suspect dès qu'on maintenait par
exemple une appellation d'origine
contrôlée ou un label ou une forme de
réglementation plus protectrice en
matière environnementale en matière
sanitaire et je crois que finalement ce
qu'il faut c'est pas c'est aussi changer
de perspective et de manière beaucoup
plus systématique quand on raisonne sur
ces questions de libre-échange se dire
et bien qu'est-ce qui est stratégique
pour un territoire très local pour le
territoire net pour la France ou à
l'échelle européenne d'ailleurs les
réponses peuvent être très différentes à
chacun de à chacun de ces échelons
chers collègues
ce président carucci
je suis malheureusement beaucoup plus
pessimiste que vous que normal
d'ailleurs ça nous caractère comme je
suis hypocondriaque
[Musique]
moi je pense que en réalité c'est un
tournant historique mais qui a commencé
il y a un moment en réalité
le libre-échange la mondialisation
les origines sont au 19e siècle un
moment où les pays européens sont en
guerre constante les uns contre les
autres et où en parallèle le
développement de la vapeur fait que la
marine les transports se développent et
on a eu toute une pensée politique et
économique sur le thème les échanges
c'est la paix
le commerce ça garantit la paix
il faut arrêter il faut que les gens
soient interdépendants économiquement
comme ça ils arrêtent de se faire la
guerre
et ça ça a été un rêve pendant un siècle
on s'est dit finalement
si les gens payent moins cher leur
produit si ils échangent davantage des
voyages davantage entre la France
l'Allemagne l'Europe les États-Unis et
tout ils ont plus de raison de faire la
guerre on va trouver et ce qu'on n'a pas
été capable de faire c'est trouver un
régulateur
on s'est inventé des systèmes plus
intéressants les uns que les autres
politiquesment économiquement la SDN
puis l'ONU puis l'OMC etc puis on voit
que ça marche pas vraiment bien moi j'ai
été ambassadeur auprès de l'OCDE j'ai
négocié un accord entre la France et les
34 pays de l'OCDE c'était surnaturel je
veux dire chacun arrivé avec sa course
et sa liste de courses pas avec se dire
où est l'intérêt collectif et puis
j'étais là comme un épicier pardon pour
les épiciers de dire un alors à toi je
te donne
3,2% de ça hein toi tu auras ça est-ce
que tu es d'accord en échange pour la on
n'a pas de régulateur et la réalité
c'est qu'on a tous cru enfin tous pas
moi mais
que le monde pouvait être uni
que les gens s'ils étaient
économiquesment socialement plus
satisfait
voilà ça y est
puis surprise des surprises depuis 30 ou
40 ans les opinions nationales
l'indépendance la souveraineté sont
redevenus des valeurs
qu'on attendait pas
et plus personne ne sait comment on gère
ça le résultat des courses c'est que
pour nous Français trop faible pour être
tout seul
on dit l'Europe
mais en face la Chine se dit mais moi
toute seule je suis à moi-même
les États-Unis pareil la Russie bon elle
a du mal mais bon elle peut rêver
d'avoir la même chose et le résultat
c'est qu'on est passé de la
mondialisation à l'affirmation nationale
et maintenant l'affirmation de blog
parce que les affirmations nationales
tiennent pas mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire en vrai moi je sais pas si c'est
la mondialisation qui est en tort mais
la réalité c'est que on est même plus
sur une BIM mondialisation on va être
dans un système de bloc
où il y aura des accords ou pas entre
blocs mais est-ce que vous croyez pas
que le vrai problème premier c'est que
ce soit mondialisation système nationaux
système de blocs c'est notre incapacité
à avoir un régulateur l'OMC trop faible
l'ONU bon ça plus à grand chose
la réalité c'est que si on veut
poursuivre il faudra avoir une vraie
réflexion comment on régule comment on
avance je suis très frappé moi
et je le dis pour l'opinion française
avec Matthieu d'Arnaud moi je suis très
Gauliste très golien tout ce qu'on veut
mais nous nous parlions il y a encore 20
ans ou 30 ans je parle pour un temps
ancien
d'indépendance
je dis ça parce que l'évolution du
vocabulaire est inquiétant parce que
il y a quoi après souvent de
je sais pas mais attention
la remise en cause de la mondialisation
moi me paraît normal parce que elle est
pas régulée mais en même temps
je vois pas où on va et est-ce que
réellement
il faudrait pas déjà demandé à tous les
états tous les blocs et tous deux de
faire des efforts sur la régulation la
réalité c'est que on peut pas tout
produire nous-mêmes moi je suis le
premier dans l'hémicycle à dire
ras-le-bol de l'aspirine chinoise
ras-le-bol de je sais pas quoi américain
que c'est en France et tout bon c'est
bien qu'on va pas pouvoir tout produire
ou alors à des coûts que ce sera
inacceptable donc il faut qu'on trouve
quelque chose qui rétablisse
l'indépendance sur des domaines
stratégiques mais qui en même temps
ne soient pas un affrontement alors
est-ce qu'on a une capacité question
facile est-ce qu'on a une capacité à
trouver un régulateur
je souscrit évidemment je pense à la
totalité que vous avez dit c'est
évidemment la grande question est très
compliquée la possibilité d'un
régulateur mondial qui serait détaché de
tout intérêt national personnellement
j'y crois très peu ce qu'on voit
malheureusement c'est que
l'essentiel de l'architecture qui a été
mise en place après la deuxième guerre
mondiale elle était très fortement
d'inspiration américaine aujourd'hui la
Chine construit un système d'instruction
parallèle avec sa banque asiatique
d'investissement etc et donc je crois
que ça relève en partie de l'utopie et
c'est pour ça que moi j'essaie de
réfléchir à des solutions
institutionnelles différentes
avec effectivement cette idée qu'on ne
pourra pas tout produire localement et
que c'est pas c'est pas souhaitable et
enfin voilà il y a pas de c'est vraiment
pas le cas mais par contre que le débat
stratégique prioritaire sur ce qu'il
faut relocaliser me paraît très
important et je pense on a manqué depuis
plusieurs décennies de penser réellement
stratégique sur sur beaucoup de domaines
parce que le
cadre mental dominant n'était pas où les
idées dominantes n'étaient pas ou
considérer beaucoup moins c'est ce ces
intérêts stratégiques soient bien commun
sur le défaillances de la de la
régulation mondiale il y a évidemment
beaucoup à dire un cas qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé et qui est très symptomatique
qui justement parlait du transport
maritime c'est celui de l'Organisation
maritime internationale
qui avait été créé justement pour
réglementer ce secteur et sur l'idée que
et bien les gens auraient les pays
auraient des droits de vote en fonction
du tenage Mondial qui représente donc
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était contrôlé par les États-Unis le
Japon la Grèce etc quelques le
Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui c'est contrôlé
par le Panama Liberia les îles Marshall
et donc évidemment il y a une
institution qui de fait est morte l'OMC
aujourd'hui est dans un très mauvais
état et l'essentiel citait le CETA ou
les traités avec le avec le MERCOSUR ou
d'autres et bien c'est des traités qui
ne se font plus dans le cadre de l'OMC
qui n'existe quasiment plus et donc je
crois que effectivement le le point de
vue idéal cette régulation mondiale
pourrait peut-être exister mais
réalistiquement le réalisme politique
nous commande je crois de chercher
d'autres voies
pour revenir un petit peu plus à micro
vu le Salon de l'Agriculture on était
hier avec la commission
économique le
la France a fait le choix d'avoir des
clauses sanitaires très respectueuse de
la personne et de l'environnement
et donc rechercher quelque part est-ce
que c'est une indépendance ou une
souveraine alimentaire de haut niveau se
donne la conséquence de ça au bout du
bout c'est qu'on a de très très bons
produits sauf qu'il n'y a que 20% de la
population française qui peut les manger
et donc est-ce que c'est possible
d'avoir des pans de stratégie parce que
quand même tout quelque part et est lié
les uns aux autres
questions
je crois deux choses d'abord la première
c'est que
on peut pas avoir enfin c'est très
difficile d'avoir des politiques
plus pendant plus davantage de
régulation et davantage problème sur
certains segments sans avoir une vision
globale plus importante à retenir très
difficile par exemple de dire on va
mettre des réglementations environnantes
sanitaire beaucoup plus importantes sur
nos agriculteurs que sur ceux du reste
de la planète sans pour autant sans
avoir un protectionnisme qui va soit
imposer des mesures miroir aux autres
pays soit imposer un surcoût à l'entrée
pour des produits produits à l'étranger
ça je pense je pense assez indispensable
effectivement sinon on se tire un peu
une balle dans le pied ou on crée
vraiment un système à deux vitesses avec
ceux qui pourront payer plus cher pour
le produit de bonne qualité ceux qui
ceux qui ne pourront simplement pas le
faire et ça je crois que c'est vraiment
très important c'est d'avoir une
réflexion stratégique globale
et dans ce cadre là effectivement faut
pas que la surréglementation qui je
crois est très justifiée du point de vue
environnemental et du point de vue
sanitaire pénalise l'agriculture et
pénalise au final le consommateur
de vos propos et m'excuser de mon léger
retard
peut-être pour reprendre y compris les
mots de mon collègue Roger carochi qui
se présente comme gaulliste ce qu'il est
et donc à mon tour pour pour dire que je
suis communiste ce que je suis bah si
c'est comme ça la vie et non non mais et
donc très très pour revenir à la fois
sur l'histoire sur la définition des
mots et sur ce que vous proposez on a eu
effectivement et je crois que c'est
c'est juste de le dire même si on a dans
le débat actuel et là d'ailleurs toute
sensibilité
comprise
cette exigence de relocaliser de de
faire plus et mieux face à un sentiment
d'une France qui aurait tout laissé
partir dans tous les secteurs d'ailleurs
et qui du coup ce serait affaibli à
l'échelle mondiale je crois qu'il est
important de dire que l'objectif n'est
pas non plus de de se replier que nous
ne serons pas tout nous-mêmes et
d'ailleurs si on revient le montant de
la guerre froide et sans faire aucune
apologie de quelques systèmes que ce
soit
à l'Est comme à l'Ouest tous les pays
n'ont jamais tout produit tout seul et
il y a toujours eu des pays dominants et
des pays dominés économiquement parlant
puisque c'est le seul sujet qui nous
intéresse mais on pourrait continuer
c'est parallélisme sur plein d'autres
choses puisque effectivement la vraie
question et que vous posez c'est le
commerce n'est-il pas en lui-même une
forme de rapport de force qui va
irriguer après l'organisation même des
sociétés donc est-ce qu'il y a avec les
ce que vous avez pointé réellement des
capacités
à penser à un autre système où est-ce
qu'il y a une donnée de départ qui faut
intégrer c'est que le commerce reste
tout de même des des rapports de force
si on revient à l'échelle micro on voit
bien que la question n'est pas
simplement je produis donc je maîtrise
le commerce c'est le cas de
l'agriculteur aujourd'hui face à toute
une chaîne dans lequel certes il produit
mais il n'est finalement qu'un très
faible qu'il n'attrait que peu de
pouvoir dans la construction du prix
final c'est vrai à l'échelle
internationale ce n'est pas forcément le
pays qui produit qui est celui qui va
s'enrichir et être le plus puissant
mondialement on a pendant tout un temps
opposé les mots de mondialisation à
d'autres qui parlent et
d'internationalise
je crois qu'en tout cas on n'a pas
solutionner la vraie question qui
l'organisation à l'échelle de la planète
finalement
du pourquoi est-ce que nous commercons
et là on aurait peut-être des bières et
je
vais être beauté et sans voir renverser
quelques tables que ce soit parce que ça
n'a aucune utilité
à trouver est-ce que l'on repense
ces règles
internationales et donc des structures
internationales et vous évoquez
l'aberration finalement d'un système de
l'OMC aujourd'hui
totalement dépassé
si oui est-ce que c'est par le poids des
états
est-ce que c'est par le poids y compris
de grandes entreprises qui à un moment
donné peuvent elles-mêmes s'interroger
parce que le poids citoyen et on le voit
dans un certain nombre de pays mais
impact aussi la réflexion des
entreprises et même si alors pour
certains c'est trop pour d'autres c'est
pas suffisant mais on a aujourd'hui
quand même un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui commencent à réfléchir
alors impact social alors impact
environnemental à tout ce que ce que ce
que ce que vous évoquez
et donc finalement avec peut-être un peu
la séance de ma part est-ce que le terme
de démondialisation ne renvoie pas une
certaine forme d'utopie qui viserait à
nier cette capacité à indispensable à
travailler ensemble je voudrais dire
faire de la coopération entre les
peuples plutôt que à devoir la nier et à
ne pas l'améliorer
très franc le mot apparaît sur le titre
de mon livre mais c'est le choix de
l'éditeur mon titre initial n'avait pas
le mode démondialisation dans le titre
parce que je pense que c'est un terme un
peu négatif qu'un réaction contre
quelque chose et qui qui a beaucoup de
limites de ce point de vue là donc je
suis pas complètement convaincu
d'ailleurs que ce soit le soit vraiment
le bon terme bon
quelques remarques sur vos commentaires
très intéressants évidemment vous le
disiez on a toujours échangé important
je crois qu'il y a quand même une
nouveauté également par rapport au XIXe
siècle que mentionnait monsieur caoutchi
qui est que pendant très longtemps le
commerce matin il a toujours existé
depuis le paléolithique au moins mais il
y a quand même une très grande
différence c'est pendant très longtemps
il restait associé essentiellement à des
biens de relativement forte valeur parce
que simplement le comme le coup de
transport restait relativement élevé
transporter des tas de cailloux d'un
bout du monde à l'autre ça coûtait
beaucoup trop cher en termes de coût de
transport et donc ne le faisait pas et
il y a vraiment une accélération depuis
quelques décennies et je crois que même
depuis 20 ans si on prend les chiffres
sur la désindustrialisation elle s'est
considérablement accélérée depuis 2000
par exemple depuis 2001 qui est l'entrée
de la Chine dans l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce et donc il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on produisait encore en 2000
qui nous ramène quand même pas très loin
en arrière qu'on ne produit plus du tout
aujourd'hui bon et donc je crois
qu'effectivement il y a c'est une
question de l'équilibre à trouver qui
est très importante sur la question des
rapports de force dans le commerce j'en
suis bien convaincu je pense pas que le
la mondialisation est obéi uniquement à
des motifs
désintéressés ou de mais il y a
effectivement eu derrière beaucoup de
traités des influences alors pendant
très longtemps américaine aujourd'hui
qui peuvent être autres et il y a même
beaucoup de
d'évidence que ces rapports de force ont
aujourd'hui un poids beaucoup plus
important qui ne l'ont eu au début de
l'OMC pour une raison assez simple c'est
que au début du Gat parce que l'OMC
c'est du 95 mais quand le Gate est créé
en 1945
l'essentiel des négociations porte sur
des droits de douane donc ça en fait
très simple si on dit ben vos droits de
douane sont de 20% les miens sont de
20%, on les abeilles c'est deux à 10%.
donc c'est très simple et c'est assez
facile de voir ce qu'un traité équilibré
parce qu'on abaisse il y a un chiffre et
on se casse le même chiffre ça c'est
très simple aujourd'hui les droits de
douane sont quasiment à 0% partout ou en
tout cas sont très très faibles donc
aujourd'hui on négocier plus du tout sur
les droits de douane mais on négocie
uniquement
sur ce qu'on appelle des barrières non
tarifaires donc sur des réglementations
et donc on dit aujourd'hui et bien un
traité de libre-échange aujourd'hui
avant ça faisait quelque part où on
disait en baisse les droits de douane
maintenant traité de libre-échange ça
fait 2000 pages et on dit et bien vous
supprimer tel réglementation sanitaire
et moi en échange supprime tel autre
réglementation etc et en fait dès qu'on
négocie non plus sur le chiffre des
droits de douane où c'était assez facile
de voir ce que tu es un accord équilibré
mais qu'on négocie sur
on va assouplir telle réglementation
sanitaire en l'échange de te l'abandon
d'appellation en échange de tel
acceptation d'OGM ou de bœuf aux
hormones ou de ce que vous voulez et
bien là le poids des rapports de force
politique et potentiellement des
entreprises qui sont derrière et
beaucoup plus importants on sait bien le
poids qu'on peut avoir des entreprises
comme Monsanto sur certains accords
internationaux etc donc je crois que ce
rapport de force non seulement il existe
mais il s'est probablement encore
renforcé depuis
depuis plusieurs décennies
après bon la question un peu ouverte sur
le
quel est l'ordre mondial on peut avoir
pour pour reprendre ça en compte je
crois que ça peut plus être une
organisation mondiale dont on pourrait
penser qu'elle serait des intéressés sur
le papier c'est très joli mais c'est
très compliqué à faire fonctionner en
pratique et donc je crois par contre que
ce qui est très important c'est même si
effectivement nos pays et la France et
l'Europe pèsent moins aujourd'hui qu'il
pouvait peser il y a plusieurs décennies
et pèseront encore moins probablement
dans quelques décennies qu'on le veuille
ou non et bien ça n'empêche pas d'avoir
une réflexion stratégique sur
des secteurs des industries un modèle
social un modèle environnemental qui je
crois sont
pour certains pas en tout cas doivent
être doivent être protégés doivent être
défendues pour des raisons non
économiques politiques
y a-t-il d'autres questions mes chers
collègues
il n'y en a pas écoutez nous reste à
vous remercier pour ces échanges
particulièrement intéressant en espérant
qu'on puisse chers Roger carochi
de retrouver un brin d'optimisme
même si on est bien d'accord que la
question est particulièrement complète
en tout cas merci à toutes et à tous
merci cher Guillaume Vime et puis nous
lirons avec attention votre ouvrage et
nous ne manquerons pas de tenir informé
des travaux de la délégation merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS bonne journée